laughs
wait I forgot who the hell is pregnant
what I found a pregnancy test at your
cabin and I checked with all the girls
that were there it wasn't any of them
Hello darling what a surprise hey
we talk maybe in private
you and me I believe she's referring to
me son please excuse us
I see I don't understand how we were so
careful I warned you about this standard
birth control methods aren't usually
effective against a Swanson I got about
a million thoughts running around my
head
but I really just want to know what
you're thinking
okay here's what I'm thinking
I was going to wait until our
anniversary take you somewhere romantic
perhaps in a canoe most likely in a
canoe
I actually built a canoe for that
purpose but given the news and given my
significant
feelings for you
now seems as good a time as any
Ron Swanson
Diane Lewis
will you marry me
yes
on one condition anything my love asking
me for anything in the world and I'll
give it to you except a destination
wedding just the opposite
we'd both be married before I don't want
anything big or elaborate in fact the
smaller the better assume you can deal
with that are you kidding as far as I'm
concerned we could go up to the fourth
floor right now
oh hello there hey Leslie what's with
the get up we're coming back from
cleaning up a Pawnee River there's
nothing I love more than squeegeeing
slime off a highway underpass where are
you guys going the fourth floor getting
married okie dokie well catch you later
what's it
are you dead you look like you're in
rictus I just I'm having so having so
many thoughts and feelings that I'm
paralyzed right now
looks like an old friend of yours is
back in town who that guy kneel that you
punked with that sleep away camp ah Neil
from Camp was the best he could pick up
a milk carton with his butt cheeks he
was so funny you know who else was funny
Bill Cosby Charles will you relax you're
gonna love Neil it's not Neil why would
it be Neil it's Doug Judy
right someone we all know in a police
capacity that makes more sense someone's
using his signature move to steal cars
plugging into the OBD port and
reprogramming the immobilizer module
that's Doug Judy's Mo but it's not him
he told me he went legit that's what he
told you last time too before he screwed
you over yeah but he returned the
diamonds to me eventually and it turned
out that was the only way to get giggle
pig off the streets wait I may be
confusing our adventures what year was
the cruise dude's a criminal people
don't change ever heard of Bruce Banner
The Incredible Hulk you might want to
talk to his shirts and pants about
people not changing
I don't want to ask Doug Judy some
questions you have his number I always
make contact through his mom I'll put
you in touch with her but remember she
thinks I'm his assistant mangy Carl and
he's a famous architect who's designing
LeBron James's new school for black
astronauts
hello Mrs Judy
I'm looking for your son the architect
yes I'm from black NASA
oh my
I didn't know I understand goodbye
so Doug Judy will not be coming in what
why not oh I see he is dead
actually it's kind of too bad we're not
coming into work tomorrow why I bet
Michael had some elaborate theme party
planned like scrambled eggs Saturday
I'm like hey everyone let's get your
boss laid Saturday
I have an announcement uh to make I am
moving to Costa Rica thought about it
for a long time now
and I'm finally gonna do it
so
I'm just gonna hop the fence and Jog
home now
great work boys We're Cops
wait where's Captain Holt who's Captain
Hook I don't know Captain Holt what and
why payday put down your weapons
what the hell what is happening we're at
the wrong Bank
I'm crashing we're NYPD officers this is
an undercover operation that's a lie
Peralta you're the golden gang we've
been on to you for weeks but we've
finally got you Hawkins you get over
there who are they you tell me you're a
crew
the goddess Jake
it's over I've never seen them before
what is going on good job everyone we
finally got the golden gang
I can't believe that you're gonna take
me down you are not gonna get away with
this oh I already did and
and no one will be able to get you out
of this one get them out of my sight
dirty cops make me sick they make me
sick I'm the sick one she's dirty I'm
clean give it up four
[Music]
five
thank you so much
[Music]
thank you
oh
we're gonna start fresh take a couple
new steps and wear our comfortable shoes
look at our history there is no mystery
the problem here was you
take off the filter from the photograph
and look who it is you see
it isn't perfect so what's wrong with
that the best things in life are free
[Music]
knowing we might fall but we might fly
who cares what they say we're gonna do
it our way
you'll be on just a few after we get
these ladies cleared off
stage that's a little sticker move right
there Little Rock everybody so how are
we going to energize our office I mean I
haven't done anything since Christmas
Pam clearly has just given up trying
so what we need to do is we need to get
things going we need to get percolating
a little bit anybody have any ideas what
we could do any suggestions yes Andy
what if we changed our outgoing
answering machine message so it just had
a little more zing and a little more pep
Zig and pep see that's the words we're
looking for yes Jim what about if we did
an even newer voicemail message that had
even more zinc and pep now we're cooking
I like this maybe a whole theme like a
rap a rap rhyme Urban thing an urban
yeah Stanley you want to help us out
with that
Stanley Eartha Stanley not me yes you
come on Stanley put your little game
down and and join the group no Stanley
we're doing having a little bit alone
I've been a brainstorm session
good this is good I'm going to grab a
glass of water